I'll set up boss actually he's the boss
I just pay for everything and design
everything make it look cool the
Avengers have you possibly stopped me
to them what we got
come to work for a living
but you slip
that's all in the swing if you step out
that door you're an Avenger
you didn't see that coming alright it's
time for some fun
you
hey youtubers is Charlie marvel just
confirm that the Russo brothers are
gonna be directing Avengers infinity war
parts 1 & 2 they're taking over for Joss
Whedon on the Avengers franchise and a
lot of you are asking why is Joss Whedon
leaving just because he's not directing
infinity war doesn't mean he's not gonna
be involved with the project Whedon is
still something of a creative director
for their film unit after the first
Avengers film did gangbusters at the box
office Marvel went to Whedon and turned
him into something of a creative
director for all of their films and TV
shows anything that they do really
inside Marvel Studios that means
whenever they're evaluating new projects
or they're trying to touch up scripts
for anything that they're doing they'll
send them to Whedon he was a big
influence on James Gunn's guardians of
the galaxy
Gunn said that when he was writing the
script for guardians he went to Whedon
for advice and Whedon said make it more
James Gunn which i think is just a great
thing to tell someone it says a lot
about James Gunn that we didn't thought
that Guardians needed more James Gunn in
the script he was mostly talking about
James Gunn's sense of humor and his
timing and obviously it paid off big
time now guardians of the galaxy is just
as big a franchise as the Avengers and
that's why I know a lot of your asking
James Gunn's name wasn't in the Hat for
Avengers infinity war I'm sure people
talked about it behind the scenes I'm
sure it was talked about because he's
ramping up for guardians 2 and there's
no way they're not gonna do a guardians
3 he wouldn't have time to fit two
Avengers films back-to-back in just a
quick update on the Marvel phase 3
schedule so I know a lot of you asked me
to include spider-man in technically
it's not a phase 3 film but because
they're sharing the character or Marvel
has a lot of creative input you could
call that Nick spider-man film a phase 3
film and that's where the Russo brothers
come in because they are attached to the
new spider-man franchise that Sony's
launching it's a little mind-blowing but
it makes sense when you look at the big
picture if you're not familiar with the
Russo brothers the ones that are
directing infinity war they're the ones
that did Winter Soldier they're also
getting ready to shoot Captain America
Civil War starting April 1st that movie
is gonna debut next spring in 2016 after
that what's gonna happen is they just
signed a contract with Sony they are
going to develop the spider-man
franchise for them let's look at the
full lineup including spider-man so we
start with Captain America Civil War
coming out May 6 2016 Doctor Strange is
next November 4th 2016 guardians of the
galaxy
is may 5th 2017 then spider-man that
first Spiderman in the new franchise
that comes out July 28th 2017 the Russos
will probably be involved with that they
haven't been announced to direct it but
they signed a development deal with Sony
so they'll probably attach to it in some
way they'll either produce it or they
will also sign on to direct it then Thor
3 Ragnarok comes out November 3rd 2017
then the first Avengers infinity war at
the beginning of 2018 then Black Panther
during the summer and Captain Marvel at
the end of 2018 so there's three Marvel
movies in 2018 then infinity War part 2
is gonna be a spring 2019 then Inhumans
comes out that same year so basically
what the Russos are gonna do is they're
gonna do Captain America Civil War next
then they're gonna jump to Sony work on
spider-man then come back to Marvel for
infinity war so they're like the busiest
people in Hollywood right now and
speaking of busy I know a lot of you are
asking why is Joss Whedon leaving the
project I already mentioned he's
probably gonna stay on his producer so
technically he's not leaving the project
he's just taking a diminished role so
that he has more free time directing any
kind of film is a huge job even small
films when you direct a big franchise
movie like Avengers especially a
two-part movie that's like four or five
years of someone's life that you just
have to throw away it's 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year until
the project is out there were a lot of
reporters that went to do interviews
with Whedon while they were filming age
of Ultron and they said when they saw on
set he kind of looked like a walking
ghost like he was so tired he knew who's
gonna be his last Marvel film at the
time you know maybe it wasn't confirmed
yet and he wanted to go to every single
meeting that he could possibly go to
that's how awesome he is Whedon
basically wanted to give input on like
every little prop that was in the movie
any little detail that he felt he could
touch up most really big directors on
films like that will just delegate to
their department heads so Whedon is
basically going to be taking a very very
long nap after Avengers age of Ultron is
out but he will still be a producer on
Marvel films what Marvel is working on
right now and now that they have the
Russos is they're working on getting the
same team that wrote Captain America
Civil War to write infinity Wars so the
same team that made Winter Soldier and
is making Captain America Civil War will
also be making infinity war any time
like a really awesome team gets together
Studios do everything they can to keep
them together just because by the time a
team gets to their second or third film
the machine that they've created just
worked so well and that's what Marvel
wants they want predictability they want
predictable success so if you're a big
fan of Winter Soldier you will probably
love Civil War and you'll probably
really enjoy infinity war it's a little
too early to predict what's going to be
going on in that movie so I don't want
to make too many predictions obviously
we know they know is probably going to
assemble the gauntlet create some havoc
they'll have to clean up in the second
part of the movie we don't know anything
about a potential Guardians crossover
the more successful guardians of the
galaxy is the less likely Marvel is
gonna be really urgent to have a
crossover with the Avengers I think that
was one of the reasons why James Gunn
was so quick to dismiss any potential
crossovers in the first part of infinity
war with the Guardians he's like we
created this big universe over here
let's give it some time to breathe
before we start mashing it up with
everyone else so they're just gonna
build out the guardians universe before
they try to crossover with the Avengers
universe even though technically it's
all in continuity together I know it's a
little confusing when you talk about
Marvel's phases as for guardians of the
galaxy 3 that probably won't land til
Marvel phase 4 just expect a new
guardians movie like every two years
after the third film though all bets are
off usually at that point the actors
have appeared in so many films that they
have to renegotiate contracts but yes
Chris Pratt all those guardians actors
signed the same six picture deal that
everyone else in the Avengers franchises
did so here's my big question for you
guys how do you feel about the Russo
brothers taking over for Joss Whedon on
the Avengers franchise Winter Soldier
was a very different type of film than
either of the Avengers films but
Marvel's creative unit does a really
good job of keeping directors and
writers consistent within the universe
so it's not gonna be like a dramatic
departure it won't look completely
different so if you want to get a sense
for a character dynamics and the
dialogue just watch Winter Soldier again
and obviously watch Civil War whenever
it comes out I think Civil War will be a
better template too because it'll have
so many more Avengers inside of it there
are a lot of people that are starting to
call Captain America Civil War Avengers
2.5 just because there are so many
Avengers in it they're taking most of
the cast from age of Ultron not everyone
but most of the cast's and kind of
changing the roles up it'll be like the
Avengers splitting in two so I'll be
really interested to see like which half
of the Avengers from age of Ultron sided
with Iron Man and which half side with
Captain America
I'm really hoping some of the next
couple of films teased out Josh Brolin's
Thanos because I think he'll appear in
guardians to hope
in a bigger way but we really have no
idea which of the other Avengers films
he's gonna appear in if any it's
entirely likely that we won't see him at
all during age of Ultron he doesn't seem
as relevant to the story as he does
during guardians of the galaxy I think
my next Marvel movie video is gonna be
like the top five new characters I'd
like to see an infinity war so be sure
to subscribe to get that I'll try and
post that later this week in case you
guys haven't seen it I just did like a
fun Loki age of Ultron
Thor Ragnarok video you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for
all my other Marvel phase 3 videos thank
you so much for watching let's all
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you